hey everybody its Jesse today I'm gonna
try to do something that doesn't happen
often I'm going to try to get done what
I said I'm going to get done in the
video description and in my tweet and
I'm gonna get it all completed in this
stream and it's gonna work that's the
goal
so I normally don't prep beforehand what
I'm gonna do but I knew there's going to
be a lot of copy and pasting so I got
most of that out of the way so I'll be
explaining what I copied and pasted but
in case you didn't read the description
yet for the video what I'm gonna do
today is get the suggestive story form
working so let me show you what that is
first and then we can go to the code so
it's right in the middle of a pulmonary
session so let me stop that here's the
form it's really simple name email and
then just a multi-line form or a
multi-line input so what we want to do
is when we submit this it's going to go
to our server
jas file and then the data is gonna get
sent in an email and we're gonna use the
send grid API to do that
so we've already have some of the setup
done for that since we're doing the same
thing for another form for the service
request form so we did that a long time
ago though so I think this will be nice
because it's way less complex it'll be a
little bit more accessible for beginners
to understand what's going on since we
don't have to handle check boxes or the
file upload field so this you know just
text inputs this is a much more likely
scenario if somebody was actually
working on a site and some they wanted
just a simple contact form you know most
sites have something like that but not
all sites will need a multi you know
multi file upload so and they won't need
to tie that into the project management
system or anything but this is
definitely a very common use case so I
wanted to do this try to do it all in
one video and have it be helpful and if
you notice the title for this video is
different than I have been doing so I
had switched for this project to just
saying what project it is and what day
it is of that project but after talking
with some of the other with Quincy and
some of the other YouTube contributors
for free code camp we decided that more
descriptive names might be better and I
agree I think for those who are closely
following the project is probably ok to
have the titles like I did have them but
for anybody that's new or just
suggestion pop-up and all they see for
the title is project to date 20 they're
gonna have no idea what that's about
unless they took the time to click and
read the description but how many people
are just gonna click on a video they
don't they don't know what it is so I'm
gonna try to do descriptive titles from
now on I may have to just change the
title after the fact because I don't
always know what we're gonna end up
doing during these streams so in any
case I just didn't want anybody be
confused by the title change I did put
after the descriptive title so it's
emailing form data with reactant nodejs
in parentheses I put p.2d 28 so that's
project 2 day 28 so it'll still be there
it'll still be in the description that
way you'll know you know in the sequence
of streams what stream or we're on but
hopefully this makes it more accessible
to new people or someone who maybe
doesn't want to or doesn't have time to
watch all of the project but might be
really interested in just one part of
the project so anyway let's um let's get
started let me say hi to everyone
all right so hey Sebastian Umberto's
says he loves the p.2d 28 tag when I put
that in there I felt like I was
describing Android in Star Wars like
r2d2 or something like sorry I'm a nerd
okay America says is it possible to
change the previous titles to match this
yes definitely and I think I will try to
go back it's gonna be tough to go back
and find the time to go back and do that
but I think I could probably go back and
retroactively Lee change the titles to
match this format that'll be better
that'll give it I think well for the
same reason that I just said you know
for this video it's just gonna be a lot
easier for people to know what's going
on
that particular video at a glance I may
actually change some thumbnails as well
so the thumbnails will most likely have
my face on them and that'll be really
easy for people to know whether they're
seeing a video from me or from from beau
or Cody or anybody on the channel at a
glance they'll immediately know so right
now you don't there's not really any way
of knowing unless you really look at the
text on the thumbnail so I think I can
get rid of the live coding with Jesse as
text and make the main text bigger and
then have my face on there and then
people will know all right that's one of
Jesse's videos so anyway that's probably
coming just some some changes that are
gonna happen at some point I don't know
when I need to get somebody to take my
pictures I can put it on there but let's
get started and let me walk you through
I do want to say Sebastian's been busy
adding on to his pull request from that
I think he submitted yesterday initially
but he keeps adding to it and it's
awesome so I'm not gonna go through the
stuff probably what I'll do is when we
finally merge that in then I'll go
through everything but for now if you're
interested in client side form
validation check that out because
there's some really good stuff in there
it's pull requests 56 that link to the
repos in the description but now let me
walk you through a little bit of what
I've done so far and then we can just
pick up from there so you can see I make
this a bit bigger for you all on the
right we have the service request form
and I was copying heavily from the
service request form so I'm gonna make
this a bit smaller for now so what I've
done is I've added in I've made it a
stateful component so
instead of a stateless functional
component which it was before we need
state so I've added some state right now
all I have in here is the state that we
need for the modal that comes up when
you submit to tell you well when it's
loading and then whether it's successful
or whether it's failed but we're
probably going to add some more state in
here to handle the the inputs we copied
over the handle the input change in some
of this stuff we can get rid of right we
don't need checkboxes on here so we can
make this a bit smaller but right now it
won't hurt anything to leave that in
there we have this handle form data so
you make a new form data object and then
we're gonna post that to our URL which
for now it's saying upload URL just
because I copied it over but I did
change the actual value to story form
that's the URL or we're actually going
to send it to so I'll probably change
that name at some point so it's not
confusing we're just doing some things
to handle the the dialogues it's not
really a big deal this is just basic
stuff from material UI and then down
here on the fields I've added in so in
our service request form we've made you
know constants for these fields so I
think I'm gonna do the same thing here
for consistency
since this form is so small it would
have been okay if I hadn't done this but
since we're copying so much I think
it'll just be easier to do it in the
exact same way on both forms so this
down here will change but I have added
you can see the the dialogue components
here and I've added a click handler here
for the form data on the submit button
all right so that's about all the
farther I got the only other thing is
that I put in the
server.js bring this out something of it
over here so for a server I've added in
a section to handle this form so I don't
think I've finished it but here we are
so we have story form and what I've done
here is just copied from what we are
doing in the service request form to
handle that I've copied everything
except for of course what we had for
file uploads and I also don't need to
send this data to a project management
system so I just copied the SendGrid
stuff and it's nice we're already
initializing SendGrid with our API key
so we don't have to repeat everything's
you see this section is a lot shorter
than what we were doing for the service
request form which is nice so that's
just the big overview once we get things
going and we can step through what's
going on and I'll explain it a little
bit more I don't want to spend too much
time time upfront explaining so don't
want to run out of time to actually get
this this going so it may seem like I've
already done a lot but don't worry I
will explain it more and I'm expecting
that it won't just work right off the
bat and that I'll need to take time to
troubleshoot so if that doesn't happen
then that'll be amazing and that that'll
be cool I like that but realistically
when I'm copying so much stuff and
trying to make it work um there's going
to be something that doesn't work so
it'll definitely take up some time on
you know trying to figure out what
exactly we need to change so let's go
I'm I'm gonna try to explain as best I
can
what we're doing I think instead of
initiating the state like this I think
I'm gonna just copy everything that's
here and then get rid of what we don't
need
so I normally do like setting state like
this as opposed to using the constructor
but since we're already using it over
here I think it'll just be easier I'd
rather just utilize as much as I can
from this then kind of changing it and
rewriting it and just you know for
efficiency and consistency all right so
we only have one multi-line field let's
get rid of all of this except r1 and we
only need name and email email here we
don't have any check boxes and let's see
yeah these are check boxes we don't need
this either okay
and we don't need this file input here
but I do want to initialize form there
okay wonderful so this date form string
box we don't need check box props there
we go there's your four string crops
okay great so just to explain a little
bit about what's going on here
there's we don't necessarily have to use
the constructor so I was saying before
we could just initialize state as state
equals and then put our object there if
we did that and and also did not bind
things here then we would need to use
some arrow functions well like this to
bind this in the proper way otherwise we
need to do this okay so you can see
right now we're only doing it once it's
not a big deal but if you had a lot of
things and you had to you know copy this
let's say you had ten different things
it's much cleaner just to use arrow
functions if you can so I think we've
talked about that and in depth a lot
more in previous streams but I mean I
thought it was worth it to go over it
and I forgot to start my phone mode or
is this just remembered all right let's
see I started 15 minutes ago so all
right I'm just gonna start it from here
then
so we'll start session from here after
this timer goes off I'll take five
minutes and go to the live chat and
answer any questions that you have I'd
like to get in at least two Pomodoro
sessions there is something going on on
campus later on that I'd like to go to
so exit three so if I can make it there
I would like to
but we'll see how this goes okay so now
that we have that there's only a few
more things that we need to bring in to
make to get it ready to at least test it
okay so we have need for Matt property
bring that in
we don't need anything with the files
we're already bringing in handling form
data we are gonna need to adjust this a
bit because you know we're still getting
the upload input things we don't need
that
Tylar close
okay great all right so let's go ahead
and let's try to remove some of the file
input stuff that we don't need so
obviously this is for file input this is
fine here
this is fine
okay great that looks good sure so close
let's change the text
new story suggestions and successfully
okay
alright now let's populate our form with
these and the data that we have in in
our constructor so you can see over here
on our service request form on the right
hand side how we're how we're doing this
so let's copy it's copy what we're doing
here I am gonna have to change it
slightly
yes a wife two cheese's
I can change it here let's do that now
while I'm thinking about it okay so I
want this to be full width so we're
using the materialized column classes so
if I want it to be full width I'm saying
on small screens and up I want it to be
12 out of 12 columns so it's a 12 column
layout
that's as well you can see with these I
wanted to only take up half the width so
in small screens still I want it to be
full width but then on medium and up I
wanted to only take up 6 of the 12
columns so not every framework has the
same amount of columns but this is
somewhat common way to do it in terms of
just the concept of splitting the page
up into columns it's kind of a nice way
to handle responsiveness and you're
changing your layout based on screen
width okay all right so that's that's
taken care of now here's where we're
actually gonna put this stuff in it now
we don't need these column classes
anymore because we're including those up
above so we're just gonna grab these two
and you can replace let me make sure I
don't get the there we go
okay we have this in as well
alright wonderful let's save that and
see what will we get on the page it
should look exactly the same awesome and
it does right so now instead of us
putting those in as we had them before
you know where you could actually see
each input now we're just iterating over
our arrays that we had here so you can
see we have name and email and then this
array which right now only has one item
in it becomes our multi-line field so
this is you know somewhat unnecessary I
guess to do it like this we could have
just put the multi-line down there but
it didn't really take that long since we
were just copying it over and this makes
it nice later on if we want to put in
fields all we have to do is just add
things to this array and if we really
wanted to clean this up we could put
this data in another file somewhere and
then just import it and that would be
good if we had really large arrays of
data and that way you know could keep
this clean and make it you know much
more reusable to just you know pull in
data different of data all you'd have to
do is just import a different different
data set or you could even pull it in
from an API or you know or anything but
for now this will work there's just a
very specific use case for this and it's
not likely to change often so this
should be fine okay so I think we're
ready we're ready to try to actually
send this and let me just do this first
I think we need to do this on our port
9000 and so we'll have to build I'm not
doing any validation right now on this
email let me I don't even think it's
required I don't need this also
right now I don't even think it's it's
said I'll get into what's going on in
the server in a second after I test this
okay
that's what I thought so let's sum let's
go here I'll probably need to build
again yeah so drive my
let me bring over my terminal
I am doing all of this in the master
branch which now that I think about it
I'm doing quite a lot so it probably
would have been better to do it in a
different branch but if I need to I can
commit this to a different branch let's
say if if it doesn't work out and I
don't want to keep this on the master
branch and it needs more work but I
think it should work out all right so I
need to build I think this will build
first when I run this no it doesn't okay
so basically we have like two different
ports running on one of them the forms
actually work on the other one it
doesn't but this one pulls its data from
the the build like the production build
files so that's why I showing two
different things for this this is still
reflecting the last time that we did a
build so I think build is still the
command to use
okay I don't think I mentioned this
earlier but while we're waiting for the
build I do have the secondary stream
going on Instagram so if you're
interested in seeing my office and
seeing me as I'm coding you can check
that out my my name on Instagram is in
the description okay great start this up
again and we should see a change there
we go
oops no we didn't see a change there we
go said manually refresh okay great so
what should happen now is that we
shouldn't get an error but let's let's
see let's just try to send this hmm okay
we did get an error let's see if we got
any message about that all right let's
check out the server and this would be
alright because then I can explain
what's going on anyway and as I
explained it I should find why I'm
getting the error
okay so we're bringing in the SendGrid
api we're also bringing in formidable
this helps us to handle form data this
is no js' we're using Express okay so
we're also using a lot of environment
variables so when you see things like
this process dot ends these are
variables that we've saved in another
file and that file does not get
committed to the repository so it's good
for things like passwords and API keys
things that you don't want the whole
world seeing you can put in that file
and then in the files that actually do
get committed to the repo you can just
add this it'll grab that value no one
will ever be able to see it okay so
that's what we're doing we're just we're
bringing in
Ingrid and we're passing in the API key
we
okay so we will be utilizing this so
when we want to actually send this to
SendGrid
we're gonna call make SG requests and
then we're gonna pass in the body write
the data and so this just sends it it's
a post you know here's our path and then
we're sending our body JSON format
we're not we're not going to deal with
this stuff with this form if you're
interested in the Reich API you can
check out one of our previous videos
right now and you'd have to look at the
descriptions but hopefully I'll get the
titles changed so there's a bit easier
to find certain titles alright so here's
where actually handling the story form
so story form so we're making a new
using formidable we're making a new form
we're setting our headers parsing the
data okay we're taking the fields and
we're creating this fields object we
should be adding key value pairs we're
also making a string and this is what we
want to show up in the email and we want
this this break here so that it makes it
readable and it's not just all the
values all scrunched together false
we're doing error handling here
all right so here's where here's what
we're doing sending the email right so
if enable send email so this is one of
our environment variables I mean this
itself isn't the environment variable
but up at the top we're grabbing that
environment variable so if we haven't
enabled send emails then this will run
otherwise it won't and this is because
we're running tests that will
automatically try to fill out the form
and submit it make sure everything's
working so we don't want email sent
every time you run that test so normally
we're going to keep that environment
variable as false but I'm gonna go in
and set it at true here in a minute so
we can test that out we have you know
just this part is pretty
self-explanatory we have a two email
from email a subject right here's your
content and you can see I've put this
field string that you saw we built up a
little farther up the type is text HTML
all right so you want to make sure if
you're putting HTML tags in your field
string or whatever you want to call this
of course you need to put HTML otherwise
it's not going to render as HTML
so this is where and I mean this is from
the SendGrid API this is where we're
adding in all of our constants here and
then now we're finally calling that
function that we went over a little bit
earlier
okay so we're sending in right this this
new mail right we're passing that in
here
and that's pretty much it so as I went
through there I didn't notice anything
other than the fact that we've said it
to not send emails right I didn't
actually notice anything else that
should be causing that to not work it's
possible that I just didn't hit save on
one of these files so I I just did that
now but my timer is up so I'm gonna take
a five-minute break right now I'm going
to go to the live chat answer any
questions that you have and then after
that five minutes we're gonna do another
25-minute session hopefully it'll just
take one more session to get this
working I think we're close all right
Sebastian says I like the live coding
with Jessie looks like a TV show yeah I
feel like that too sometimes that's like
the name of this of the show that was
actually I didn't even pick that I think
it was maybe it was Bo I think it was Bo
it's possible as Quincy but one of one
of those guys just they titled like one
of the videos that and just said hey
here's an example you could use this and
I thought it fitted that explains
exactly what's going on
so it just left it kamal says this looks
so complicated just started watching
though so not sure if you're still
watching because that comment came right
at the beginning but yeah coming in at
this point the project it probably looks
complicated because we have so much
going on but if if you can start closer
to the beginning you'll see that we
started just from basic things and just
build little by little so it'll be a lot
easier to understand then but even if
you can't watch all the previous streams
I'm trying to do my best to explain as
I'm going along and I feel free to ask
any questions and the live chat and
hopefully you could at least get some
tips out of it
okay Sebastian says to push his changes
to a branch so people can submit pr's to
that yeah I would definitely do that
sorry about that I wasn't even thinking
thinking about that so all I'll probably
have time to get to that before I leave
today I might actually merge it into
master or at least into the into the
branch that we were doing the
server-side validation on as well
because I like how it looks now I know
there's a little bug with the with the
UI but I don't think it's actually that
terrible I have some ideas for how to
fix it but even if we didn't fix it I I
don't think it's it's that bad I think
the value of having that immediate
validation far outweighs the slight
shift and kind of increase in spacing
that happens
Umberto's says I still like the
thumbnails as they are though unless
you're really looking to have your
person your face be known for providing
incredibly helpful project tutorials
yeah so I I originally didn't want to
put my face on there because I don't
know I just I like I didn't want it to
be about me I just wanted it to be like
about the code but I don't know so
there's two reasons like one thing is I
I don't think I can separate like me and
my personality from what we're doing now
because it is me on here you know that's
that's what's unique about what I'm
doing is is me right the code is the
code but so anyway I'm not quite as
worried about that now as I was
initially I didn't want it to seem like
I wanted people to look at me or
anything but also videos that do have a
face on it tend to be clicked more often
than videos that don't so just in
general so it might not be a bad idea
and there's that immediate recognition
that'll just help people differentiate
since we have so many different people
contributing to the free code camp
channel right now it might make things a
little bit more clear
so anyway I'm gonna try but I'm not
ready for that yet I don't have any any
pictures ready or I haven't even tested
out how I would do it so it won't happen
immediately probably not even next week
it'll be later on
heart Harshit says why don't you use
node mailer basically I I already had
SendGrid account and it was just really
easy to send grid so when we set up the
other I was already using send grid on
the other version of this project which
is not using node so I needed to send I
needed to send the emails client-side
for the version of this that's live
right now that we're redoing and so I
used email Jas and send grid to be able
to send client-side through San grid so
since I was already doing this through
SendGrid kind of in a roundabout way I I
decided just to stick with it for this
so i don't know i haven't used node
meddler before so it may be a better
option in general for node but anyway
that's why I ended up on with Sangren
all right awesome so last thing I'll
I'll go over
actually I'm almost let me just finish
up what's in the live chat now and then
we'll start she'd just take me a minute
so Umberto is getting a gonna get a job
offer today most likely so awesome
congratulations on that definitely let
me know how that goes if you take the
job yeah that'll I'm really happy for
you so yeah it definitely keeps us up to
date number two is working on c-sharp
dotnet tutorial series on a project that
he's working on so I'm looking forward
to that as well that's that's awesome we
actually I've been mentioning that we've
been going through the process of trying
to hire a developer here for for another
department here at the University of
that work at and I was on the team that
was interviewing all the candidates and
we finally found a candidate that I
think we're gonna extend an offer to but
they're going to be working with c-sharp
and net and that so they're going to
need to brush up on that so umberto if
you do that series I'm going to refer
that person to your tutorial series to
help them get up to speed because I
certainly don't do very much with
c-sharp or net so this other person is
going to have to handle all that and
I'll handle all the Java scripts though
okay
all right so I see Sebastian and Patrick
were given some advice here on the air I
was just kidding so let's go back to
this I'm going to start the timer and
let's go in so it seems like Sebastian's
saying that the air was given from
client side since you don't get any data
from the response in the client side
also Patrick says I would have seen some
output in the terminal that makes sense
I see there are some other questions in
there now I will get back to the
questions after I finish this this
session so don't worry if you can stick
around
I will we'll get to all the questions
okay so let's check yeah I actually
didn't check the console at all when I
tried to send that so let me just submit
alright I'm getting nothing
[Music]
yeah are we sending anything
um let me just try to add all these in
yeah I didn't think we're doing any type
of validation so since we've already
checked out the server and it's probably
not the server since we're not getting
any oh wait a second we're getting
something now sure there's 159 all right
I'd much rather see an error message
than nothing when something doesn't work
159 okay let's see all right so do we
have I thought I'd check this out before
I started the stream and we needed that
okay that right we definitely didn't
need this let me go through let me go
through this slowly all right so that's
good that's open
it's closed this is always an issue and
I'm copying and pasting things and
modifying as I go making sure that I
have all the right brackets and
parentheses making sure they're all
closed
all right that's this looks good
this looks like I have everything let me
go back to that message
Oh missing I thought it was I'm missing
it here's after after yes there we go
okay miss that before all right let's
try this again yeah it's done okay
awesome so look we've got our fields
which are nonsense right now but it's
sending the data to the server and we're
at least getting this back in the
console now the next step is on my other
screen I'm gonna go to my environment
variables and I'm going to enable
sending emails so I can't show you my
environment variables because then you
you see everything my API keys and stuff
and I have to change them so trying to
think did we have did we put in a test
one I think we did I just wanted
something to refer you all to if you're
not familiar with what it should look
like I think I think we have there we go
so we have an example of the environment
variables so this is what I'm seeing on
my other screen except it actually has
the keys in there so this is what I mean
really simple file okay if you want to
do a comment you just put a hashtag and
then you just put in the name and
usually it's you use all caps and
underscores and then equals and then
whatever value you have and then you can
write you can put whatever variables you
want in here so anyway that's that's
what I mean by environment variables
okay so let's do it again and see if I
get Nina
actually let me think will this work
yeah it shouldn't I was just trying to
think if I'd have to build this again or
if it would still try to pull the
environment variables from here let me
see my build files
I guess I can just check my email and if
I don't see it then I'll I'll try to
build again let's see okay Sebastian
said I just try to restart the server
actually I don't have my gmail open let
me open it up okay yeah I didn't get
anything so let's restart the server see
if it doesn't work this time then I'll I
guess I can try
doing a repo
all right awesome so I got the email and
pop this out to show you all so there we
go
there's the email I know it's really
small but it's really basic doesn't look
great
obviously you know before I would want
this to be live I would make this look a
little bit nicer but you see it sent it
to my email so let's let's check this
out
just to kind of step through everything
so the date is come back here
all right to our server das file and
we've put in the two email which was my
email address right so we know it sent
it there the from email so and the
subject you can see here new suggests
the story form submission and here's the
from email test at example.com and then
here's our values so everything works
well we want to add to this which I
don't know how much time I have right
now so what we would want to add which
may or may not get to this today is we
want to send an email to the person
who's filling this form out so we would
want to grab that email address value
and then also send that to that person
as well I can't quite remember how to do
this with the API but I think it would I
could probably just add a comma and then
put another email address although I may
want to actually send an entirely new
email so I would probably just repeat
this and have a different you have
different content based on one going
the users submitted the form and another
one going to the people in my department
who would be getting this this form so
I'd want to do that I'd also want some
validation so client-side we would want
to make sure that the email address is a
real email address and we'd probably
want to make sure that the name is a
valid name so if somebody just put in
all special characters or all numbers
that's not really a valid name so we
want to check for that we probably want
to check to if the story was longer than
a certain amount right nobody's going to
suggest an entire story that's let's say
four characters long so we'd want to
decide on a reasonable length that we'd
be willing to accept and and then that
way that will cut down on maybe some
submissions that either are accidental
you know somebody hits enter clicks
before they were ready or maybe you know
potentially some spam submissions so
we'd want to do that client-side and
then potentially we could server-side as
well so we would do a check certainly to
make sure that we actually do have a
valid email before we try to send to
that email address so I actually didn't
haven't done that server-side yet so I
have to figure out how to do that
server-side but I don't want to be
sending the sender and API some invalid
email addresses yeah we just if somebody
submits something that's an invalid
email certainly we can't send that user
an email back what I'm thinking though
is if that were to happen it would
probably be somebody trying to
circumvent the client-side validation so
probably don't even really want emails
from those people so at that point we
would just stop and not even send an
email to anyone maybe you could send one
I can maybe send one to me just to say
hey something weird happened with this
email check it out and I can check the
form just to make sure nothing's broken
at that point but anyway you can see now
you kind of see where I'm going just to
add some extra things we would want to
make the content of the email look nicer
yeah but that's basically it so we've
gone through I know I realized a copy
and pasted a lot at the beginning so it
was a little bit of a cheat in terms of
you know I didn't really go from scratch
but I mean when do we ever make
something direct you know from scratch
we're always borrowing from previous
work that we've done or from other
people's work proper properly attributed
and yeah so in this case we benefit
greatly from work previously done some
by me and a lot by pull requests from
others so you can see you know we
borrowed from the service request form
and so this will be available on the
github repo I'll commit this actually
since this works I think I'll just
commit it now and then that way if
anybody's new we're not really familiar
with yet you could see the process and
committing and pushing so let's go get
status and you can see we've changed the
server dodged ass file and our storage
is file all right that's what we want to
see because we did change those files if
we saw some other file in here that we
we didn't think that we had changed
maybe there's something accidental then
we could check it out but now I'm gonna
go get commit and I'm gonna put the a.m.
flag and that means we're committing so
we're adding we're committing with a
message all at the same time so it just
saves us
that and let's say send story form data
email okay great so now our tests are
gonna run we've set up and by we I mean
who set up the tests Kevin
so Kevin contributed and set up some
tests so the tests are gonna run we're
also running some automatic code
I guess linting and formatting and so
that runs as well so it makes our code
adhere to standards we're using the
standard j/s standard and there we go so
all the tests are passed i actually got
another email I think so I got some
emails from the service request form
because I had set that environment
variable so right now we don't have any
tests written for this new form that
we've put on here so we'll probably want
to write a test for that as well let's
see all right so everything works so
that's now committed but it's not yet on
github if we want this to be reflected
on a github repository we have to push
it so do git push origin master is where
on the master branch there we go so
we've just pushed our code from the
master branch on our local machine to
the master branch on the github repo so
if you go there now you'll be able to
see all the new stuff that we had just
done it may look slightly different
since we auto formatted everything but
that's a good thing because we all have
the same standard formatting even if you
were to clone this repo and run it on
your own machine if you go to to commit
it would format it the same way as well
so you don't really it's kind of nice
you don't have to worry about learning
the code style that I prefer and I don't
have to
about pool requests coming in in a
totally different style so if you can
set something like that up on your
project I think it's really helpful
especially if you have more than one
person but even if it's just you it is
still helpful to keep yourself the code
that you're writing clean as well so
we've kind of demonstrated how to do
this in in previous videos I think yeah
there is a title of the video that says
something like using prettier in
standard J s so if you look through my
playlist it's in the previous project so
not project two but in the first project
you'll see that if you're interested in
setting something like this up all right
well that before I forget I'm gonna set
this environment variable to false on my
other screen so I don't get I don't
accidentally spam myself with lots of
emails so I think now now I'm going to
go to the live chat and take your
questions so this end up being a short
stream today but like I said there is
something I'd like to do in about a half
an hour here on campus so right now if
you were just here for the code I'm
gonna do question and answer so if you
can't stick around for that or don't
want to stick around for that thank you
so much for watching and I'll be back on
Monday so please join again if you can
and otherwise if you have a question
please put it in the live chat now I
don't think there's a ton of stuff in
there so it shouldn't take me too long
to get through so don't don't wait to
ask or the show might end before you get
it in there if for some reason you can't
stick around I'll still try to answer
your question and you can catch the
answer on the recording which will be
available on free code camp just a few
minutes after the live stream ends
otherwise you can ask me questions on
any
social media channel that I'm on I want
most of the most popular ones I prefer
direct messages on Twitter or you could
just you know tag me in a tweet or
something so
but whatever you want to do so I am
going to scroll up a bit so I don't miss
any of the questions and I'm just going
to go down through since there's not a
lot in here I'll try to read out the
comments as well and please feel free if
you're in the live chat to add your own
answers and opinions to the questions
I'm certainly not an expert so if you
have a lot of experience in some area
where someone's asking a question I
would really appreciate you kind of
adding you know your expertise to the
discussion okay all right so Kenny says
no idea what is going on but looks cool
and complicated for me now good job
though so Kenny Kenny asked that a while
back not sure if you're still here Kenny
but did I already answer this one let's
calm down I thought I already answered
this maybe I did or I commented on it or
at least one that was similar so just
briefly I'll kind of sum up what I said
before complicated now because we're on
day 28 of this project and we've had
lots of pull requests from other people
so it does seem really complicated but
we just built up little by little so we
started out small with just really basic
project and then kept adding and adding
so it's not it's not anything that you
all couldn't couldn't do yourself you
just remember you know it's it doesn't
get this big and complicated right away
yeah you just break off tiny little
pieces that you can handle and just kind
of work on it if you could see I have
this Trello board here which gives us
you know these little chunks and let's
see two probably three
actually that's not bad we got got this
done in less time than I expected I'll
probably not move
done though because I still want to add
some validation and things as well so
it's not entirely finished but you know
the basic functionality is certainly
there
but anyway I wanted to show you the
Trello because you can see you know
everything is broken down into very
small manageable chunks I try to break
things up into chunks that are eighth
Pomodoro sessions or less if it's bigger
than that you can probably break it down
even smaller
the bigger the in terms of the time you
think it will take the less accurate
your estimations will be so it's better
to try to break things down into smaller
chunks if you want accuracy in your
estimates you can see I don't always do
that like for this one I actually know I
estimated 5 and I've taken up 13 and I'm
still not done with this one so not
always accurate in the estimates but
anyway just kind of like trying to be
encouraging if you're coming in in the
middle of this you know don't think this
is like too much for you it's it's just
that you know we're very far into this
project at this point so I really think
that a lot of you could definitely get
something out of these videos even if
we're farther along and you know ask ask
all the questions that you need to oh ok
Patrick said it should be suggestions
were sent or suggestions was sent so did
I I think I made some type of
grammatical mistake somewhere so let me
let me check that out this is the server
I don't know if it's in server or maybe
to be
your story suggestions worse and okay
alright your story suggestion was yeah
that makes sense
thanks Patrick
aslam says hi oh I've done a bit of
nodejs now but I'm struggling with
understanding structure it all seems a
bit messy compared to PHP any
suggestions I'm not 100% sure what you
mean by messy I have worked a bit with
PHP it's possible that I don't like I
said since I don't understand exactly
what you mean by messy maybe I'm kind of
off here but it's possible that you know
JavaScript is a different you know a
little bit different style than some of
your other server-side you know
traditional server-side languages so you
know that could make it seem messy as
compared to something else if you're
coming from JavaScript enough from
something else that would seem normal
obviously so I would probably say it
could it could be the case that it's not
inherently messy it's just a matter of
what someone is used to in the
comparison between those things but I
don't really have any suggestions in
terms of trying to make it be less messy
like I said because I'm not although I
do have some experience with PHP I
wasn't that into PHP so to me no doesn't
look messy my server JS file looks messy
B it certainly does it's huge and it
needs some refactoring but in general
note doesn't look messy to me so sorry
it's not really much of an answer
probably isn't that much help to you but
maybe someone else in the chat possibly
has some some further insight into that
Sammy says any thoughts on using
functional libraries like Ram Das I had
a user and uh I've seen some talks at
conferences about Ram de and it seemed
really interesting to tell you the truth
I can't I can't remember that much about
it from from what I had seen of it
before so sorry I can't really give give
my opinion other to say that I do
remember when I saw the presentation I
thought it was really interesting but I
haven't had an opportunity to use it
since then and you know because of that
I really only I don't remember that much
about it
okay so we had someone I'm not even
gonna say who it is but it's just funny
someone came in and into the live chat
and said yo yo yo yo yo like twice just
a bunch of years hi
bye i subbed i unsubbed LOL and then a
bunch of emojis and then some more yos
so not really sure what's going on there
but it made me laugh a little bit
let's see some guy says and that that's
actually the name this person's Twitter
YouTube handle is some guy says I'm
getting confused learning reacts
patience patience yeah it can be
confusing at times I'm trying to learn
Redux with reacts right now and I'm
getting confused about that although I
think I'm having some errors that aren't
exactly Redux related and I think that's
causing even more confusion because I'm
looking for the solution in terms of how
to do Redux and now I'm starting to
think that the problem is somewhere else
which is even worse because now I have
no idea
no look but I definitely understand the
confusion it did take me quite a while
before I really understood enough about
react to be confident and to build you
know real like production sites with
react Umberto says this is one we're
talking about the new web developer that
hopefully will be starting soon Umberto
says well I hope they're already
familiar net but I hope that if they're
not that whatever I end up publishing
actually helps yeah I'm sure sure it'll
help this person is has worked with
dotnet and c-sharp a little bit they're
a lot more familiar with PHP I was
impressed with their problem-solving
skills in the technical interview we
actually just had him do some JavaScript
like algorithms and and I was impressed
so ran into a little bit of a little bit
of trouble but didn't give up and was
able to like very calmly logically work
their way through and find where the air
was so anyway I'm hopeful that someone
like that will be able to pick up on
things and persevere and learn what they
need to what they need to learn
okay so Sammy says in response to some
guy that codecademy has a good tutorial
then you can create the react projects
on free code camp so yeah actually
that's good I did start out with the
code Academy tutorial it was nice
because you didn't need to worry about
setting anything up on your own machine
I know one of the big barriers for me
and getting into react at first was
webpack I was confused by webpack I had
originally started out using grunt then
I moved to gulp like I think a lot of
people did and then I I was trying to
make the switch to web pack and learn it
but I just kept getting confused and so
it wasn't until I found create react app
and next j/s and I think I I think I
first started to learn react before
create react dad came out so I kinda had
taken a little break from it for a while
and then that came out and I came back
to it that made it a lot easier for me
because it handles a lot of the setup
and you can just get to react so that
really helped me out so if you don't
want to deal with the setup stuff at
first then code Academy is a great
resource
Patrick s when are you going to be
putting this putting this on a server
next week I hope to put this on the
server next week so at that point
that'll be cool because you all can test
it out without having to run it locally
I need to put it up somewhere so that
people in my department can can work
with it so I just want to wanted to
finish up things like I needed to get
this form functional because people are
going to test it and want to know what's
what's going on I need to put in there's
a bit of new information that needs to
go in there so I need to finish what we
were working on yesterday putting in a
modal with some extra information about
photography projects once I get that in
then it'll be fine to demo so at some
point next week I'm probably going to
set up a server
I'll just do a droplet on digital ocean
I think just kind of a basic five dollar
droplet I'm gonna run
ubuntu 16.04 we're gonna run node we're
going to do nginx as a reverse proxy
will set up a an ssl with let's encrypt
so I have done that before so I don't
know if I should do another stream with
that maybe I will
we'll see I need to repeat the exact
same thing but it might be worthwhile
we'll see let me know if you all have
any opinion whether you'd want to see
the server setup or not because I can
definitely do that you know earlier in
the day and not not on the stream
all right so mike says hi hey Mike how's
it going thanks for joining
Oh Sebastian says Monday I'm moving to
Germany don't know when I'll be able to
watch the streams again oh wow sorry to
hear that Sebastian well try to keep in
touch if you can't if you can't make it
for the streams for the live chat at
least try to keep in touch you know
other other ways through you know
through really whatever you you prefer
you know Twitter or whatever and I
really appreciate all your contributions
in the live chat I hope you can you can
get back get back in here and be able to
see the stream soon I hope everything
goes well in the in the move
Brian says hi great tutorial awesome um
I'm glad you liked it thank you for
saying that I appreciate it and welcome
claude BS is their video of that set up
already yeah so there's I have done
basically that exact same setup I've
done already the only difference is that
I was building with NEX Jas instead of
create react app and that's not really a
huge difference almost all the steps are
exactly the same so yeah so I don't know
I have to think about it and I welcome
your feedback on that I don't want to
bore people by doing things again I
don't think that there's very much that
has changed probably nothing has changed
in the setup if it was later on down the
road and some things changed like maybe
like the way you set up let's encrypt or
a newer version of you know Ubuntu or
something like that
maybe it would be worth it I don't know
I'll think about it
Patrick says I like that kind of thing I
don't need any help with that but I like
things where I can be helpful okay cool
all
I'll keep that in mind I think about it
William says currently following your
first project is there a sequence
between the first and second project a
correlation okay a correlation between
the first and second project they're not
connected I mean they're two completely
separate websites they're connected only
in the sense that they're both react
sites we did so I think if we borrowed
code or anything like that I don't even
think that we really borrowed that much
code we actually did we did borrow some
of the code so other than the fact that
they're both react and that some of this
the code was was borrowed and reused in
this project there's there's not really
a correlation I mean they're both done
for the same you know for the same
University but you could definitely
watch either one you like it's not like
you'd have to watch the first one to
understand the second one actually with
that being said with that in mind it may
not be a bad idea to do the server setup
again because there there may be people
who for whatever reason aren't really
interested at all in project one but
they're interested in product two or
whatever future projects we do so
instead of making people go back and
watch the previous videos okay I'm still
thinking about it as a few more pros to
doing it now
yeah William so so it's fine if I just
start watching your project - since it's
ongoing
yeah definitely definitely William said
thanks for answering you're welcome yeah
no problem
but yeah definitely you can watch you
don't need project one for
- and in fact I intend that a lot of
what I do will be self-contained so each
project will be self-contained you don't
need to watch the other ones at some
point I am going to do some updates on
project one I think in October I'm going
to do some updates so I'm not sure how
I'm going to handle that in terms of
will that be considered like a third
project or will I just kind of tack it
onto project one and maybe make separate
perlite playlists for each project I'm
not on it since URL I'll handle that I
think it kind of depends on how much I
need to update it if it's just going to
be a few days you know it's that's not
really a big deal but if it's going to
be like weeks of work then I have to
think about how I want to treat that but
I've reached the bottom of the live chat
and I see Sebastian says update project
one day one we need may update like the
title to make it more clear that it's
project one day one yeah I definitely
should I've thought about that before
it's just every time I think about it
I'm not really in a position to change
it I mean I'm busy or I'm streaming or
doing something so I'll have to make
more of an effort to remember and do
that yeah that's that's definitely a
good suggestion thank you alright so I'm
gonna wrap things up here thank you so
much to everyone for watching for
contributing in the live chat for
contributing with with pool requests
thanks for your questions
and in all your encouragement I really
appreciate it I will be back on Monday
and oh
I'm not sure what time I'll let you you
know I'll let you all know what time
it'll be a notification in YouTube and
I'll put it on Twitter as well I think I
should be good to go for the for the
normal oh wait
Tuesday yeah Thank You Patrick
Monday's Labor Day so in the United
States it's a it's a national holiday on
Monday so I don't I'm not working so I
won't haha Thank You Patrick
I don't know how I forgot that I won't
be here on Monday on Tuesday I will be
back so I won't yeah so I won't see you
again for three days so anyway have a
very nice weekend and I'll see you back
here on Tuesday